[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il était une fois une petite fille et
son robot
un jour alors qu'il jouait dans leur
jardin
un bocal est tombé du ciel et s'est
écrasée par terre une petite chèvre en
est sorti et elle a commencé alors
raconté qu'elle venait d'un monde
parallèle où il y avait un grand
marécage autrefois luxuriants et
florissant dans lequel elle habitait ce
marécage été gouvernée par un gentil
prince et tout le monde vivait dans le
respect et l'harmonie sauf que ce gentil
prince il avait un fils plutôt impatient
et feignant dans le genre et un jour ce
fils de prince a décidé qu'il voulait
avoir tout tout de suite et sans trop se
fatiguer alors il a commencé à mener des
expériences scientifiques à base de
plastique et il en a fait plein plein
plein plein tellement qu'il a fait
n'importe quoi et son laboratoire a
explosé le marécage s'est retrouvé
complètement sans dessus dessous
il a commencé à fuir le plastique a
commencé à l'envahir et l'intelligence
de l'infâme fils de prince a eu
tellement peur qu'elle est parti se
cacher super loin quelque part par là
alors l'infâme fils de prince est devenu
si bêtes sans son intelligence qu'au
lieu de réfléchir à correctement réparer
son mariage il a décidé d'envoyer ses
petits soldats capturés tous les
habitants pour les enfermer dans des
bocaux boucher les trous et colmater les
fuites
sauf que ça ne marche pas du tout
et là vous vous devez sûrement vous
demandez pourquoi je vous raconte tout
ça alors bonsoir moi je m'appelle et les
old man je suis illustratrice et je
viens de ce que j'appelle une génération
plastique
depuis que je suis toute petite je vis
entouré de plastique mais jouets étaient
en plastique mais abîmé meubles mes
crayons mais mon maquillage contient du
plastique
alors on m'avait dit que c'était normal
que c'était fantastique et moi dans ma
vie d'avant bon ça m'a pas trop déranger
et là c'est un peu bizarre je vous dis
dans ma vie d'avant jugeant peu une tête
d'enfant je sais mais en fait pour moi
il ya deux ans tout a basculé
j'ai fait une grosse crise d'épilepsie
et mon cerveau un petit peu grillé j'ai
perdu une partie de la sensibilité du
côté gauche de mon corps j'avais un peu
de mal à articuler
j'avais beaucoup de mal à écrire ça a
été une période
franchement nul j'avais super peur de
devenir un légume et il faut savoir moi
j'ai un esprit de contradiction à peu
près grand comme la salle et j'aime pas
trop quand on fait ce genre de coups un
peu nul
du coup je suis rentré pour me rééduquer
toute seule à la maison
alors pendant des semaines et des
semaines j'ai tracé des lignes le plus
droit est le plus serré possible pour
réussir à contrôler mes mouvements et à
ne pas les croiser sauf que forcément je
me suis beaucoup ennuyé en faisant ça
alors j'ai commencé à dessiner et au
début mes dessins étaient super moche
mais je me suis accroché j'ai dessiné
tous les jours pendant des mois et à un
moment j'ai finit par dessiner
correctement et surtout je m'amusais
énormément alors je me suis sentie à
l'étroit un peu sur une feuille de
papier ce que moi je voulais dessiner en
grand et sans jamais m'arrêter
donc j'ai commencé un dessin géant que
j'ai posté par ligne sur instagram
et que j'ai appelé le dessin sans fin et
j'ai eu des abonnés plein d'abonnés
tellement qu'un festival m'a proposé de
les exposer ici à rennes super première
fois de ma vie trop cool sauf que mon
dessin à ce moment là il faisait 15
mètres de haut
ça fait un immeuble 60 cm de large ce
qui est complètement in exposable donc
comment faire si je dessinais la suite
plus tôt alors je vais faire une fraise
de deux mètres cinquante de haut 5 m de
large et tant qu'à faire je vais
rajouter de la réalité augmentée dans
vos super idée bonne idée ouais et c'est
aussi à ce moment là que j'ai commencé à
réfléchir
je me suis dis donc j'ai commencé à
réfléchir mais là pas tout de suite si
je me suis dit qu'en fait
potentiellement plein de gens allaient
pouvoir voir cette fresque que j'allais
dessinée et que c'était justement le bon
moment pour arrêter de dessiner
n'importe quoi et de commencer à un peu
à m'occuper de cette histoire de
plastique dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure
parce que pour vous je sais pas mais moi
ça me pose un méga problème en fait
quand je réfléchis à tout ce qui a
changé dans ma vie depuis 2016 je vois
surtout que la seule chose qui n'a pas
changé c'est qu'on vit toujours entouré
plastique
il y en a absolument partout et moi on
avait appris à l'aimer en fait mais là
c'est plus du tout fantastique et plus
tard ben j'ai envie d'avoir des enfants
et ça me brise vraiment le coeur de
savoir que la seule chose que je vais
avoir à leur proposer c'est une poubelle
géante en plastique et qu'ils devront
juste faire avec
alors pourquoi ne pas essayer de changer
un petit peu ça avec mes dessins c'est à
ce moment-là que j'ai écrit la grande
histoire du dessin sans fin pour pouvoir
sensibiliser les enfants qui viendraient
voir ma fresque
c'est l'histoire avec la petite fille et
le robot dans la suite
ils vont accompagner la petite chèvre
dans le marécage pour retrouver
l'intelligence de l'infâme fils de
prince et le remettre bien profondément
dans le crâne
et en chemin ils vont aider tous les
habitants à ramasser le plastique et à
nettoyer le marécage
c'est un grand défi que je me lance
cette année c'est la première fois en
combinant cette fresque la grande
histoire du dessin sans fin et la
réalité augmentée
j'ai envie d'aider les enfants à
développer un réflexe celui de ramasser
le plastique et les déchets sur le sol
pour les jeter à la poubelle
à chaque fois qu'ils en croiseront parce
que les réflexes je pense que c'est
important de les développer tous par
exemple moi quand j'étais petit
si on m'avait dit que le sport c'était
super chouette et ben j'aurais pas
autant de mal à sortir de chez moi pour
courir 20 minutes parce que j'aurai
l'habitude de le faire et surtout
j'aimerais ça eh bien là c'est pareil
l'idée c'est de rendre le ramassage du
plastique amusant pour les enfants alors
dans ma fresque j'ai caché de nombreux
déchets bout de plastique et je vais
demander aux enfants d'aller les
chercher
et une fois qu'ils auront trouvé
l'endroit tout triste et terne dans
lesquelles les déchets sont cachés ils
pourront scanner la fresque avec une
tablette et déclenché une vidéo en
réalité augmentée dans laquelle des
petites mains d'enfants viendront
enlèveront les déchets en lèvres le
plastique et en faisant ça animeront les
personnages ramèneront la couleur la
musique et la joie dans le marécage
et c'est là que le réflexe qui prend
racine en fait les enfants s'amusent et
s'est ramassé le plastique qui devient
fantastique de vidéos en vidéo les
enfants vous jouez et intégrer le
réflexe appliquez ensuite dans la
réalité
ramasser une bouteille sur le sol c'est
plutôt nul est tout seul ça devient
amusant et gratifiant on peut sauver les
chèvres les petites filles les marécages
mais dans la vraie vie
donc c'est un grand projet pour moi
cette année c'est un vaste bazar mais
c'est parce que j'aime bien les projets
compliqués mois et ce soir je suis pas
là pour vous demander de faire la même
chose je suis là pour vous proposer de
participer pour vous motiver à faire des
petits trucs dans vos vies quotidiennes
pour que les générations futures ne
soient pas à leur tour des générations
place
ic où j'ai eu une idée un peu comme le
trash tags pour ceux qui connaissent
j'ai fait un calcul hyper scientifique
ce soir dans cette salle on est à peu
près trois mille trois cents personnes
après si chacun d'entre nous se motive à
ramasser trois petits légers par jour
pendant une semaine
juste une semaine eh ben ça fait patate
à 70000 déchets quasiment ramassés en
une seule semaine
ce qui est énorme je trouve peut-être
vous trouvez et vu que je sais très bien
que on est tous encore un petit peu des
enfants
moi oui j'ai réfléchi à une façon de
rendre ça un peu plus amusant et donc je
vous propose de prendre en photo chacun
des déchets que vous allez ramasser
pendant cette semaine et le poster sur
vos réseaux sociaux avec le hashtag
poubelle sans fin pour inciter vos amis
vos connaissances à faire la même chose
et que tous ensemble on commence à
s'occuper un petit peu de cette histoire
de plastique
parce que si on travaille tous bien nos
pages facebook nos pages instagram
devrait pas tarder à ressembler à des
énormes poubelles et finalement ce soir
je suis venu pour vous demander est ce
que ce serait pas mieux que ce soient
les réseaux sociaux la poubelle sans fin
plutôt que notre planète
merci
[Musique]